yusuf mumbai comes to this hospital
three times a week for physiotherapy
he was shot and left for dead in 2000 by
troops loyal to gambia's former
president yahya yami
yasufa says he was only able to regain
partial use of his hand after 22 years
of physiotherapy
doctors say his survival was a miracle
even eating is quite a struggle
the gambia's truth
reconciliation and reparation commission
recommended he be paid compensation
but he returned the four hundred dollars
he was given i didn't need money i need
my help my head is more important than
anything else
and that is something neither his
attackers the truth commission nor the
current government can give him back
survivors and victims families have
singled out members of the hits court
known as a jungler for most of the
atrocities committed under former
president yaijali they want them tried
and punished but activists also want
political leaders to be held accountable
for not stopping those crimes
journalists and red cross volunteer omar
barrow was killed while helping victims
shot by the security forces his family
believed he was targeted because of his
work as a journalist
his widow our sunni isn't as confident
the report the government will release
will bring closure
you just cannot reconcile and forgive
people without knowing how can you
forgive somebody you don't know who who
killed your husband how can you forget
that person
you have to have justice then then after
we forgive we reconcile but before that
we need justice
for her justice means punishing those
responsible for the crimes committed
including
who she says still has some influence
here in the gambia
the government says it took this long to
ensure a thorough and satisfactory job
of investigating allegations of rights
abusers
officials hope government action on the
rights commission's recommendations
could heal wounds and reconcile a nation
struggling to come to terms with its
recent past
but most victims like yusuf mumbai
remain skeptical
ahmed idris al jazeera banjo the gambia